hello everyone thank you so much for
coming my name is Becca Skinner and I'm
a National Geographic young Explorer and
an adventure photographer and before I
get started and tell you why in this
photo I'm carrying 110 liters of camera
gear across the coast of Canada I just
wanted to give you a little bit of
background so I'm based in Bozeman
Montana it's so beautiful and this is a
little cabin that I that I stay at quite
often but most of the time I'm on the
road and I know most of you have houses
or permits and maybe you're looking out
the door at a front yard or backyard but
my view often looks like this this is my
front yard or backyard
I'm also based out of my bright yellow
truck named happy and very unselfie that
National Geographic yellow but this is
my view a lot of times when I'm on the
road and I was spending so much time on
the road last year that I actually had a
friend help build me a bed in the back
of the truck it's way more comfortable
that way so you can see the two storage
systems on the side and then I have this
bed in the middle my dog and I fit
perfectly in that little Mick and
obviously a coffee device in the corner
and I would argue that this is actually
more comfortable than my bed at home so
I know I just said I spend a lot of time
outside or on the road but I just wanted
to give you some statistics about how
much time I actually spend outside so
last year I kept track and last year I
flipped outside for 242 Nights which
estimates the roughly eight months of
the year that means I was inside about
123 nights which also means I only took
about 123 showers last year
which is not that much but don't be
defeated I showered this morning please
still come talk to me after the show but
most my showers looks like this so being
an adventure photographer means I get to
see incredible places my day is not ever
the same it just keeps me on my toes as
you can see there's quite a diversity of
images in this picture but um yeah it's
always different and that's part of the
reason I love this job
the only thing consistent is I drink a
very very strong coffee good morning but
90% of my job is really fun and right
now I'm working for a lot of outdoor
companies creating content and a few of
these photos have not yet been published
so you get to see them first
and so yes quite diversity 90% of my job
is really fun and the other 10% is
totally miserable well kind of being an
adventure photographer also means I'm
dealing with the elements 24 hours a day
7 days a week when I'm out in the field
not something you'd like typically think
of when you see beautiful images on
Instagram so like this day we were up at
about 8,000 feet and the winds were
about 30 miles per hour and it got to
the point where it was such a terrible
blizzard outside that I could no longer
see the people I was taking photos of so
I hunkered down for about 10 minutes
till the whiteout passed and then we
decided it was probably okay we could go
home or those days like that where the
elements turns me into a beautiful lady
Gandalf
with a nice beard on this morning it is
negative 20 degrees I am wearing five
jackets in this picture and the
condensation from my breath and because
it's so cold outside created this
awesome ice
my hair and I couldn't pull it apart
until it melted which was one until
about 11:00 in the morning and at these
temperatures are all so I've been very
aware of frostbite and one of the people
I was with started to get frostbite on
her toes
so again turned around and went back
because also part of this job is knowing
when to call it or there are days like
this it poured rains last year I was on
an expedition with this guy Verde
Gregory and we were filming for birdies
digital series for Nat Geo Wild it's
called wild life and it just finished
its last episode so you can still watch
it check it out but in this photo we're
about 75 miles off the coast of
Vancouver Island we're the only people
on the island and we wave that our float
plan is they dropped us off hoping that
we had enough food and gear and that our
Sat phone was working and birdie is
building a wildlife hide which is
basically a wildlife blind and it breaks
up your shape because we were on the
coast and we wanted to try and find
coastal wolves for this expedition we
needed a way to break up the shape so we
would sit in the side and this actually
contributed to about one month of my not
showering because you can't alter your
scent and wolves will smell you or
wildlife has pretty great sense of smell
so and no showering was a strict rule
for this trip and I feel bad for a float
plane pilot that had to take us home
but in situations like this where it's
pouring rain you're starting to be kind
of concerned about your gear and that's
a question that I get a lot is how are
you dealing with your gear when you're
out in the field and the elements for
the whole time and the truth is it gets
first priority in your head
you must have a good tent you need to
really trust your equipment but there
this is about a quarter of our gear
actually I'm holding line camera there's
a few more behind me that you can't see
this is a four person tent and in the
space is where two other people would
typically lie was all of our camera gear
when you want stretch out you can't
because there's batteries behind you
back side you and we had to start
sleeping with batteries in our sleeping
bag and it's not because I have a weird
thing with batteries and it actually
helps prolong the life of them so if
they're not or may not been cooling and
warming up and cooling you can just
stick them in your sleeping bag and your
body heat helps keep them warm and they
last longer but I haven't always been an
adventure photographer I haven't always
been on Instagram which I will tell you
about but I started Instagram in 2012
and at the time and it was just being
used as a really casual way to share
parts of your life and no one was really
using it for business or for promotion
and so part of a really fun part of
pulling together this presentation is I
dug through my images and found my very
first Instagram photo which I am so
excited to show you it's really
compelling my dog this is my dog vida
boo and I this was her sunbathing
position and I saw her draped over this
garden hose in the backyard I thought it
was funny because she pulls her legs up
like a t-rex when she's like that and
obviously pretty comedic so on my iPhone
thought it was funny snapped a photo put
like four filters on it because that's
what you did and then post it at
Instagram so not a lot of forethought
also my favorite section at the
bookstore
and again thought it was funny took
photo with my iPhone posted immediately
not a lot of force left so I had
Instagram as an app and I was also
storytelling on the side but it never
really occurred to me that I could do
both that I could combine that effort
because no one was really using it like
that so in 2010 I had won a grant from
the University of Wyoming to go document
post-hurricane Katrina New Orleans and
how they were covering and so this was
kind of my first experience in the field
and that project led to a National
Geographic young explorers grant
document post tsunami Banda Aceh Sumatra
that was pretty decimated by the tsunami
and if anyone in the crowd is between
the ages of 18 to 25 or if you know
someone in that age that you think might
be interested in the young explorers
grants they're such an awesome
opportunity and please come talk to me
afterwards because it got my foot in the
door with National Geographic and it
funded my first big field project was
documenting in the tsunami and I had a
kind of a similar idea for my young
explorers grant on how Banda Aceh was
recovering and I feel like this photo
really sums it up in my entire project
into this image and I like to play a
game with this photo called I'm the boat
yeah sort of in the middle this barge
had floated inland and you can see the
coastline in this photo so a couple
miles it floated in and it settled there
and instead of tear it apart
thinned onions decided let's build
around it so you can pay a penny and you
can walk up onto the barge and look out
over the city of Banda Aceh Sumatra but
really really interesting so I came back
from my young explorers project so
Oh jazzed about photography like this is
what I wanted to do I was living my
dream but there was this big jump in my
head between what I just got to do as a
grantee and and being a full-time
photographer and I didn't really know
how to make that jump
so I was working for the state of
Wyoming as a grant writer and I decided
to save up a bunch of money and that I
would go travel so I ended up taking
time off of that job and traveling to
just shoot photos because that's the
only thing I knew how to do and the only
thing I really wanted to do so this road
trip ended up being about 32,000 miles
around the American West and just with
my dog and I this is on a small break a
a mouse had climbed into my engine
compartment and at the time I was
sleeping in this vehicle like like I was
sleeping in the truck and then the
entire night I could hear it run across
the dashboard and then kept me up all
night there's like 5 a.m. in the morning
and a little bit I know my traveling
around the west and creating these
images just because I wanted to and
because I loved it it was creating this
kind of visual diary on Instagram I made
the switch I stopped taking pictures
with my iPhone and posting them taking
photos with my camera and posting them
there and I had no idea that people were
paying attention until I started to
gather this audience and when I hit
20,000 followers my mom wanted to get me
a cake and I was like none
no no no people don't do that thank you
all right very good
but um I didn't really realize that
people wanted to see what I was shooting
until I started to gather this audience
so it's the very end of 2014 I decided I
would make the jump into full-time
freelance hood and it was like the major
major leap of faith for me and so as
soon as I publicly announced that I was
going into full-time photography I
immediately panicked it's like oh no
maybe this isn't right and so when I
panic I go fly-fishing so I left for a
week on a fly-fishing trip in the
backcountry of Montana and when I came
out of the backcountry I had an email
from someone I thought it was spam it
wasn't spam and it was from a
fly-fishing company that wanted me to
shoot their entire campaign for that
year and when I finally spoke on the
phone to them and asked them
how on earth they had found me they said
through Instagram and that was my first
freelance job was they found me there so
for most of the half of 2015 the first
half this is last year and I got that
fly-fishing job in 2014 and then I
didn't get another email for month again
panic so I decided okay I would go on
more trips because I knew that and it
was a gamble but it was an investment in
making more images things that were
compelling and things that I wanted to
see and I think it shines through when
you're doing something that you really
love and so I started creating things
like this just totally diverse and then
it stressed me partly through 2015
tonight
kind of start leverage the audience that
I had built on Instagram two companies
or four projects that I wanted to do I
wanted to travel and so I would send out
most companies and say are you
interested in this expedition and that's
how the expedition to Panama was born
this is my friend Clare Fiedler who's a
fellow young Explorer grantee and my
favorite expedition partner and we had
been in contact with this company called
Oro kayak and we had proposed it was
Claire's idea to circumnavigate this
island outside of Panama is called
bastimentos and you can see it up there
with a little pin it doesn't look that
big but um it was a four-day trip and we
had two objectives for the trip one view
a social media story for or kayak and
then two to write a blog post for
National Geographic adventure and there
were only some problems to begin with
and problem number one or complication
number one Claire and I had never worked
together and this may not seem like a
big deal but sometimes your expedition
partners and or sometimes your friends
don't make the best expedition partners
so we had been talking about a much
larger circumnavigation we decided we
should probably make sure we lie to each
other
Before we jump into a multi month trip
so we started having these Skype phone
calls and we're at this time in two
different countries and both of us are
traveling really frequently so this
guy's conversation was the last one
before I went to Panama and I'm
obviously have a headlamp on and I'm
like standing on my tippy-toes at the
top of a peak because that's where I can
get cell phone service and Claire is in
her room and
and she doesn't get cell phone service
on the island either so were like try
and piece together these Skype meetings
ha problem number two complication
number two we had never used the kayaks
before keep that one in mind
complication number three we had no idea
how much carrying capacity they had
which might not be that big of a deal
thinking about it fit when you start
adding things up like our self supported
gear and tent sleeping pad at food water
and then camera gear and I don't know
how many of you have a camera body with
its various heavy heavy appendages but
there it starts to add up so we had no
idea how much would actually fit into
the kayaks and just a little bit of
background on the kayak very start as a
two by three Fox and they unfurl
into this large lake I actually saw
Claire nice standing in front of roughly
about sixteen feet and they are really
well the website and directions said
give yourself fifteen to twenty minutes
to put them together and so Claire and I
are like cotton that's great we can do
that so we put it off until the last
thing we did it took us a little bit
longer than 15 minutes it took us about
two and a half three and a half hours
they are a little bit more complicated
than we initially thought
so you can see a getting darker and
darker the other thing that we kind of
put off because we didn't know the
carrying capacity was the grocery list
and knowing that we were going to be
kayaking in multiple miles a day and I
put together a last minute but very
calorie efficient grocery list and with
what was available at the Panamanian
grocery store on island of del Toro
cheese peanut butter apples water rum
calorie efficient so Instagram became
this wave to tell these little vignettes
these stories and or as I like to call
them learning curves of what was
actually happening on that expedition so
learning curve number one Claire and I
are in a rush to get out the door start
packing we finally figure out that
everything fits in the both wins both
float whenever cute we finally start
paddling and it's been a year and a half
since I've kayak I was carrying 110
liters through the temperate rainforest
in Canada I had not been ruined still a
few miles into the trip I am hoping that
my arms fall off to give me an excuse to
stop paddling against the current and I
start to kind of panic because the
current is really really strong on the
ocean side and so it's pulling me one
way and I'm just digging with my left
hand and I'm starting to panic and
Claire's a little bit away from me and
so I paddle in and I yell Claire how
much further do we have to go and she's
paddling digging with her left paddle
she's like I don't know look at the GPS
I'm paddling and like you have the GPS
and we both kind of turn and look at
each other and stop paddling and realize
that we left the GPS and yes this is a
circumnavigation there's an island on
one side there's an ocean on the other
it can't be that hard right well there
are these mangrove entrances with GPS
coordinates the mangroves are so thick
from the outside and a lot of places
that we were going to stay we actually
could not locate where the mangrove
entrances were and this is when we
finally found one on the first night we
were going to fishing lodge and they
just happened to be blowing through
conch shells and you're like let's
follow the conch shells that sounds
promising and we ended up there so good
so this is the Instagram post that we
did with this the best and scariest
parts about expeditions are the unknown
they were quite a handful on this trip
Clare Fiedler tending to the fire after
a long day of open ocean dealing with my
seasickness and the last GPS learning
curve number two because we were lost we
were supposed to sleep at an indigenous
village and both of us were so excited
about this because the southern part of
the island is not a tourist destination
it does not get visited very often and
we had the opportunity to camp with the
indigenous people in their village which
was so exciting as because we were lost
we couldn't find the mangrove entrance
we decided to camp on this beach instead
at last photo that you saw that's where
we camped and we decided the next
morning that's okay we will find this
village we will portage which when full
of possessions the kayaks so when we
lifted them up Sportage
started to bow the other way under the
weight which is not something you want
from your foldable kayak so scratch that
plan dump out all of our possessions
refold the boats start portaging the
boats with our camera gear on our backs
and we start to go down this trail which
it starts on this bridge and then the
trail is off to my right and we start to
go down this bridge and we run into a
local so exciting and the local gives us
some very very key information Clara
Fiedler in the short portage originally
Clare and I were going to portage our
gear for a mile to an indigenous village
ready for packing up start hiking we
were told that the dense jungle path we
were going to use was actually a
crocodile trail narrowly avoided that
one so Clara and I had come up with a
hashtag paddling Panama kind of see it
down there on the left and and we use
that to curate these images together to
do this eventual blog post - here on my
left and Claire's house circumnavigated
an island by kayak is like speed dating
and we we were laughing and joking while
we were paddling that expeditions are
like Explorer
matcom because you're trying to put out
these small little fires when you're
panicking and you're like how do you
deal with it like that means you okay
we're good we can go into the field
together or match so Instagram has been
so much for my life and it's really
broadened my world it's allowed me to
connect with people that I that I never
dreamed of connecting with and share my
images just outside of my community and
I will continue to share it's also
introduced me to some of my best trim my
best friend Heidi and these are seven
year old chickens sitting on our heads
it's introduced me to some wonderful
people and it's not as it's broad in my
world it's really it's really shrunk it
to I use it to check conditions of
places if if I'm going somewhere and
need to look up the weather then I will
look up the location and and see what
has briefly been posted I obviously use
it for business and but yeah also shrunk
my world and introduced me to some
really wonderful people it's such a
great tool for connecting so I hope you
will connect me there too
[Applause]